​It takes a mighty hero to tell Captain
Marvel to cool it.
Natalie Portman, who will reprise her role
as Jane Foster in the upcoming ​Thor: Love
and Thunder,​ had a few choice words for
fellow MCU star Brie Larson after the actress
posted an Instagram shot of herself wielding
Thor's legendary hammer.
In case you weren't aware, Portman won't simply
be returning as the Odinson's love interest
in Love and Thunder; she'll be taking up the
mantle of Mighty Thor herself, following her
character's recent trajectory in the pages
of Marvel comics.
It appears that, at least for awhile, there
will be two Thors and as far as Portman is
concerned, there's no room for a third.
Earlier this week, Captain Marvel and Avengers:
Endgame star Larson posted a photo to her
Instagram, which appears to have been taken
in an office at Marvel Studios.
Larson captioned the image:
"Not to be whatever, but…
I told you I could lift it."
Larson's caption is a reference to a 2018
interview with Buzzfeed Brasil, during which
she was asked whether Captain Marvel could
lift Thor's hammer.
She responded with an enthusiastic "definitely."
It took her a little while to get around to
proving it….
"I have nothing to prove to you."
...but never say that the good Captain doesn't
put her money where her mouth is.
Larson’s post has so far garnered over 1.8
million likes, but sharp-eyed Instagram users
noticed that Portman was quick to chime in
with a response.
Portman wrote:
"Hey muscles, easy with my hammer!!!"
Portman's remark has amassed over 50,000 likes
of its own, and the display of good-natured
rivalry between two of the MCU's biggest female
stars prompted an outpouring of love from
fans.
Black Panther star Michael B. Jordan also
chipped in with a couple of laughing emojis.
The announcement of Portman's return to the
Marvel fold was one of the biggest surprises
of the studio's San Diego Comic-Con 2019 panel,
and it seems like Foster's already getting
excited to wield Thor's hammer.
It's always great to see these displays of
camaraderie between Marvel's stars, but unfortunately,
it seems like it'll be awhile before we see
either of them on the big screen again.
Thor: Love and Thunder won't hit the big screen
until November 5, 2021, and a likely sequel
to Captain Marvel wasn't discussed during
Marvel's Comic-Con panel.
Hopefully, when Mighty Thor meets Captain
Marvel for the first time, she'll like the
cosmic hero as much as her predecessor did.
"I like this one."
Marvel's Phase 4 will be significantly shorter
than previous phases, running only through
2021 and consisting of five feature films:
Black Widow, The Eternals, Shang-Chi and the
Legend of the Ten Rings, Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness, and Thor: Love
and Thunder.
So far, only one Phase 5 film has been officially
announced: Blade, which will star Mahershala
Ali in the title role.
Assuming that Phase 5 will also span a couple
of years, it's highly likely that we'll see
Larson's Carol Danvers back on the big screen
sometime in 2022, or 2023 at the latest.
It's also not clear how large or small a role
Portman's Mighty Thor will play in the MCU
going forward; perhaps, once series star Chris
Hemsworth hangs up the hammer for good, Portman's
Foster will carry the franchise a little further.
It could also be that some Phase 5 guest appearances
are in the cards, possibly even in Avengers
5.
Fans are already hoping that the as-yet unannounced
movie will be a massive crossover which could
feature the likes of the X-Men and Fantastic
Four, newly available to the MCU after parent
company Disney's acquisition of 20th Century
Fox.
We'll just have to wait to see what the future
holds for these two mighty heroes, but in
the meantime, we'll just have to make do with
some winking Instagram banter.
There's probably more where this came from.
It turns out that, just like the rest of us,
it's tough for even superheroes to resist
taking friendly pot-shots at each other on
social media.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.